psychics the only people with more
misplaced confidence than Michael
avenatti now chances are you haven't
thought about psychics in a while which
is weird there's not really a whole lot
else going on but if you watch daytime
TV at all you'll see that they pop up
all the time when she was just a toddler
she's a wife and a mom who also happens
to talk to dead people
please welcome celebrity pet psychic our
next guest is a clairvoyant to the Stars
bond they're all psychic okay
I guess it's good that at least dr. oz
isn't wearing scrubs in that clip but
I'd still like him to do more to signal
he now lacks credibility as a medical
professional I think a sandwich sign
that says walking joke is the clothing
choice that I would be comfortable with
and look before we go any further I am
NOT going to be litigating whether
psychics are real in this piece for one
they're not see no litigation required
also for anyone who does believe in
psychic powers I know there is nothing I
could say that could convince you
otherwise logic isn't the reason that
you believe in them and it won't be the
reason that you stop which is not to say
that I won't be showing you clips of
psychics up but that is only
because it's really funny this is a girl
who you said was beaten and killed okay
this little girl is me and you told
somebody that she's dead wait a minute
you didn't disappear I'm right here well
that's interesting isn't it yeah
that is interesting I guess her psychic
abilities didn't include predicting when
she'd be utterly humiliated on national
television and look it is easy to
dismiss the psychics as a joke really
easy fun too
but the fact of the matter is one recent
poll found 4 in 10 Americans believe in
psychics just think about that
statistically that means out of all the
people who saw John Travolta's Gotti
movie four of them believed in psychics
so whether they are real or not is
incidental
what matters is a lot of people think
they are and the psychic industries both
larger and grimmer than you might assume
by one estimate it's a two point
two billion dollar industry and there
has been a lot of predatory behavior
when the the FTC settled charges with
the companies behind these psychic
readers Network in 2002 the one that
featured Miss Cleo they found that over
one three-year period they had charged
people about a billion dollars and a
collected half of it they took in five
hundred million dollars I had no idea
psychics could make that much money
he's like finding out the second richest
person in the world behind Jeff Bezos is
this gamestop employee named Greg I mean
good for Greg I guess but now I've got a
lot of questions about Gamestop and
literally everything else so tonight
let's take a look at the psychic
industry particularly one of the most
insidious parts of it
mediums people who claim to be able to
communicate with the dead they are
everywhere on TV some even have their
own reality shows she's a professional
psychic Mary knows bad 9:00 on TLC
spirit is important to me just as
important as my hair and my nails medium
only on TLC the crazy thing about these
shows is how they choose to focus on the
psychics personal lives who gives a
about that if I actually believed they
could communicate with the dead that is
the only thing I'd want to see them
doing the Long Island medium can ask
Abraham Lincoln Gandhi and Shakespeare
anything she wants so tune in next week
as she thinks about getting bangs I want
to mixed mediums make for compelling TV
most people have seen at least one of
them bring someone to tears with
messages from dead loved ones like this
did you lose your husband man your
husband wants to thank you for caring
for him and allowing him to leave the
physical world with dignity and grace
now that woman is clearly genuinely
touched although I will say it is weird
that the conduit to the afterlife is for
some reason Theresa Caputo living proof
of what would happen if you added too
much baking soda to Edie Falco
and while we're watching people tear up
can seem incredible the techniques that
psychics use to achieve those moments
are significantly less incredible
because there are two basic techniques
that psychics tend to use the first is
called cold reading it's basically
taking high probability guesses like I'm
sensing a loved one who had problems in
the chest area or is there a J or an M
in a loved one's name here are some cold
reading in action alright
and is there in theat like a Daniel
David like there's a big D so for me
it's initials it's usually on months of
the year like December being important
who is the MRNA mark Mary Marie they
don't have to be past they could be here
in the physical world
you know Maureen Mary Ann there's an M
name where's the M connection to you
does someone have a scar and the bun of
foot I do thank you cuz your daddy is
telling me there's a scar on your foot
she departed of Alzheimer's or some type
of dementia or something of the brain
and that you had to make choices and
decisions connected to her departure did
anybody have either a brain tumor brain
aneurysm or a cerebral cerebral
hemorrhage not connected to him not
connected to you somebody behind you had
that Oh someone been under had that nice
save buddy interestingly often turns out
that a psychics wrong guess is just
energy from somewhere else in the room a
room incidentally that he's very likely
to have someone who had one of the
problems he just listed because
cerebrovascular diseases are the fifth
leading cause of death in the United
States it's like asking a roomful of
praying mantises has anybody here lost a
loved one because you ate them after
having sex you know all those little
green hands are going up
the secret of cold reading is the
broader the generality the higher the
chance it resonates with someone it is
the same reason that fortune cookies
predict romantic developments ahead and
not your wife is gonna seem icy
withholding around the 12th of the month
that's because when she asked you to
handle the thing with the grout in the
shower she didn't mean be the plumbers
point of contact we keep abreast of
every step of the grouting process she
meant she wanted it off her plate and
she just feels like text in the middle
of the work day asking if she thinks the
landlord is gonna ask her the plumbers
insurance that's the off her plate
that's just new air and filling up the
plate instead of the plumber does that
make sense
Aaron it's not the garbage disposal
installation all over again lucky
numbers 8 14 and 23 and sometimes
psychics may make laughably sure bets
for instance here's John Edward in
Huntington Long Island a town where
nearly 1 in 5 residents are of Irish
ancestry is there a Brian Flanagan or a
Flynn or O'Sullivan or O'Reilly or some
type of whose past Brian Oh something
Flanagan Sullivan something like that
what are you doing Brian Flanagan or Oh
Flynn or Oh something he's supposed to
be speaking directly to people's dead
relatives not trying to guess the name
of the Lucky Charms mascot for the
record that leprechauns name ibrahim
abdul hameed been selling if that
surprises you maybe update you
antiquated Irish stereotypes
and once a psychic has you on the hook
they use your responses as well as
nonverbal cues that you may be giving
them to make narrower and narrower
guesses until you are amazed at what
they've just done of course it's not an
exact science it's not a science at all
and sometimes things do go wrong in fact
let's pick up John addresses reading
with the family of Bryan Oh something as
he doubles down on a bad guess I'm kind
of getting the feeling of not liking the
older female like not liking the mother
figure so if you tell me that you didn't
like you're his father's mother then I
would understand that I don't think I do
I don't think I do
I just want to be really clear because I
can't tell you what you want to hear I'm
gonna tell you what they're showing me
and if he's calling your mother a
I'm gonna pass them on so what you want
about John Edward he's sticking to his
guns there none of that maybe this
energy is coming from somewhere else in
the room nonsense this time no no this
time he chooses to go for it yeah Bryan
thinks grandma's a and you know
what so do I now in fact hang on Amelia
Earhart just came through and she just
called grandma the c-word so don't be
mad with me be mad at Amelia Earhart
cold reading is basically just a magic
trick and yet prominent smart people are
willing to co-sign on psychics abilities
a few years ago Tyler Henry the
Hollywood medium and anime drawing of
Jared Kushner went on The Today Show to
do a reading of one of their anchors and
I'm afraid it's the exact Today Show
anchor that you are hoping slash
dreading it is there's a reference to
fishing but he's talking about being
spoken out loud to I know what this is
actually I don't know if you're aware of
this but he's acknowledging an
individual will be out on a boat and
it's like I'm sitting alone and I'm
fishing and I'm thinking that and he's
having me acknowledge this feeling of
like I'm there with you I'm there with
you um you know my dad shared two
passions with me he shared golf and
fishing night
and I do go out fish a lot alone on a
boat and this idea that that that might
be a time to communicate with him or
that he is attempting to communicate is
phenomenal to me yeah phenomenal it's
clear that Matt Lauer is touched there
and this time he didn't even have to
press were subordinate into doing it
maybe Tyler Henry just took a shot that
an older straight white male was upwards
of lukewarm toward fishing if he did
that would be cold reading but he may
have been using the other technique here
of hot reading which involves doing
prior research on a subject so for
instance he could have read articles
where Lauer talks about his father's
passion for fishing or seen interviews
little hour gave like this one my dad
taught me had a fish when I stand in a
trout stream now and I've got the waders
on and I've got a fly rod in my hand or
I'm fishing for bass I think about
sitting in a boat with my dad look
maybe Tyler Henry genuinely accessed the
afterlife an action which would
fundamentally change our understanding
of everything on earth or maybe he just
googled Matt Lauer dad and hit the
jackpot so so to recap hot
reading researching people beforehand
the even lazier skill than cold reading
which basically involves
indiscriminately shouting the names of
dead Irishmen in a hotel ballroom and
what's surprising is whichever technique
Tyler used Lauer fell for it and he is
smart he's a sophisticated Manhattan sex
monster but he fell for it
hard so hard he wanted to make it clear
to the viewers at home that this was way
more than just your standard TV
I tell you got home I cried I did plenty
of crying when I got home it's amazing
we want to let you know season two of
Hollywood medium with Tyler Hannah it
almost seems weird to be doing it as a
promo right now because it was so much
more important to me than a promo it
premieres Wednesday August 10th on our
sister network e well everything about
that is a little strange not least the
fact that it is weird to envision a
scenario in which something happened at
the Today Show offices and then Matt
Lauer was the one who went home and
cried
look you can see why people are
vulnerable to psychics
a message from a lost loved one is
something many people in the midst of
grief would do anything for and psychics
may tell themselves that they offer a
harmless way to deal with painful loss
in fact just watch as Theresa Caputo
pretty much spells that out in response
to a fairly obvious question so when a
tragedy happens let's say a murder if
somebody comes to a loved one and the
spirit of the person who was murdered is
there could that spirit potentially tell
you who did it they will acknowledge
maybe the relationship but never will
call someone out on the name why is that
my thing how I use my gift is I only
want messages that I got to help someone
for the healing process oh come on first
to be clear if I was murdered I would
definitely name names as a ghost it's
not like one of the rules in heaven is
go snitches get go stitches as we all
know the only rule in heaven is no
the clouds seriously it's a real
problem up there and to be fair I'll get
it they're so fluffy and you might say
at this point hold on where is the
downside in telling people their
grandmother loved them but I would argue
that at best it is reckless for a
stranger to take a stab at ventral
acquiring the dead loss is complicated
and mourning doesn't look the same for
everyone but at worst when psychic
abilities are presented as authentic it
emboldened a vast underworld of
unscrupulous vultures more than happy to
make money by offering an open line to
the afterlife as well as many other
services take Rose marks she
ran a lucrative psychic ring and in 2014
went to prison for defrauding clients of
more than 17 million dollars much of
which came from best-selling author Judy
burrow who marks had promised to
reconnect with her dead son and the sick
thing is parents in crisis are
frequently actively targeted by psychics
at their most desperate moments John and
Joann lowitz er have been searching for
their 17 year old daughter Ally since
she vanished last year but when the case
made national news
the Houston parents say they became
inundated with calls from so-called
psychic detectives they say some even
showed up at their front door promising
their psychic visions could help bring
Ally home he guaranteed me they need to
find Ally in three days and what parent
wouldn't be excited to hear that you're
gonna have your daughter home in three
days that is absolutely horrible because
the last thing any parent needs in that
situation is having to fend off an
attention-seeking parasite who feeds off
personal tragedy like a human sized deer
tick and the problem is TV actively
enables that ghoulish nurse the Montel
Williams Show regularly featured Sylvia
Browne a well-known psychic
who advised parents with missing
children on how to locate their kids on
one episode she advised the mother of
Amanda berry a missing child who had
been kidnapped now a man that was
actually alive and watching that episode
from captivity and after she eventually
escaped she talked about how watching it
had felt I would watch her every time
she was on Montone I say I wish my mom
would go in there and then she could
tell my mom that I was alive and then
I'm okay she but Sylvia Browne breaks
Luana's home I just hate this she's not
alive
I just broke down crying because I
couldn't believe she said that and that
hurt even worse that is heartbreaking
and Sylvia Browne is clearly an awful
person for doing that but I would argue
that Montel also bears some blame for
giving Browne a platform to begin with
put it this way if Oprah interviewed a
live alligator and it ate four members
of her audience I'd be angry with the
alligator but it'd also be kind of angry
with Oprah Sylvia Browne actually died a
few years ago or did she
people have been wrong about that sort
of thing before maybe she's alive and
watching me refer to her as dead the one
thing I know for sure is that Montel
Williams his show is definitely deceased
but but but daytime shows are still
holding hands with this
just last month dr. Phil had a psychic
detective on to help solve a cold case
and why would he do that the only
logical explanation for letting a
professional guess awayin would be if
dr. Phil was actually the murderer and
he was trying to throw people off the
scent but apart from that explanation
that now makes a lot of sense there is
no explanation although I will say this
every now and then when handled
responsibly a psychic on television is a
delightful thing just watch this
spectacular local news investigation of
a psychic named Deborah Dominique who in
exchange for 160 dollars
met an undercover reporter at a Denny's
our producer met her at a coffee shop
saying she wants to know what happened
to Matthew the ten year old boy in this
photo
after staring at his photo she uses a
special pendulum claiming it allows her
to talk with the day and then she claims
she is connected directly with memory
but is he because we're pretty sure
Matthew the boy in this photo is not
wearing white or in heaven in fact we
know he's wearing black and is alive
because you're looking at him sitting in
the boat right behind her yep
that boy is indeed in the opposite of
heaven he's in a Denny's but wait wait
till you see exactly how they Buster
because it is just perfect I'm Curtis
coming from channel 13 how are you
showing her the picture of Matthew she
tells me she thinks he was taken I
understand you said you thought he was
deceased yes I believe he could be I've
got news for you it might come as a
shock but he's very much alive oh that's
great he's actually standing right
behind you right now
it is great it is great it's utter
perfection the only way that could have
been any better is if the first thing
that kids said to her was hey mom and I
would argue that that is the only
responsible way to put a psychic on
television humiliating them with a ghost
boy in a Denny's parking lot because
this surprisingly large often predatory
industry relies on popular culture to
lend it credence and validity to put it
another way every time a psychic makes a
grieving widow cry on dr. oz 10 con
artists get their wings and that is a
problem because there will always be
people who feel an urge to reach out to
psychics in their time of need
so if you or someone you know is one of
them I may have a small way to help here
sadly this isn't really the best format
for me to show you so please join me on
the set of my new daytime talk show
instead
welcome back to wakey-wakey with John
Oliver it's some time between 9:00 and
3:00 in the afternoon then but my next
guest is a Staten Island psychic and
author of the book these freaking
spirits let me tell you please welcome
Wonder Joe Oliver
thank you for having me John thank you
it's lovely to have you here now Wanda
if you look familiar to some viewers it
might be because you're also my beloved
wife I'm it's freaking angel she is no
quick question Wanda Joe what happened
to your accent are you from the south
I'm not from there anymore that makes
sense no wonder when did you first
realize that you had incredible psychic
abilities oh well it was right after I
saw a thing on TV about how much money
psychics can make and suddenly I was
like me too
hashtag me too oh no no no that's that's
not that's actually a different year my
gift with the world no Joe I understand
that you've graciously offered to give
our viewers psychic readings for free
bingo bango as part of a court-ordered
settlement I've been forced to set up a
website Wanda Jo the free psychic calm
just log on now and you can get a
breathing for me Wanda joke just like
this okay they want me to acknowledge an
EM connection that could mean Mark or
Mary or Megan it could be someone who's
passed or still alive it also doesn't
have to be a name it could be any word
that starts with M or has an M somewhere
in it maybe maybe Museum Oh hamper it
could be an upside down and like a W or
sideways then like a three or an E
anyway that person he or she wants me to
tell you that the time you had together
was really special to him or her wow
that is phenomenal to me and it almost
seems weird to be doing this as a promo
right now because wonder gave me a
reading yesterday and it was so much
more important to me than a promo I
cried all the way home I told them none
of his dead relatives wanted to talk to
him that's that's so then the point is
go to wonder Joe the free psychic or
medium impressive calm and get a free
psychic reading we promise it will be
exactly as accurate as any psychic
reading that you would pay money for
oh wait wait I'm getting a voice through
for someone at home hold on your
grandmother's a Wow
[Applause]